Julian Assange is arrested Attorney
General William bar goes on offense
against the so-called deep state and
Ilhan Omar complains about Islamophobia
after tape emerges of her talking in a
weird way about 9/11 I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
Wow it is news overload today I mean
just too much news happening in a very
short period time Michael avenatti new
indictments released against him
apparently he was stealing money from a
paraplegic person hero of the resistance
over there I mean just breaking news
it's all insane we'll get to all of it
in just a second but all the news may be
stressing you out stress is a worldwide
epidemic we are working longer hours
we're inundated with the constant news
cycle we're more connected than ever
well that can easily affect our
well-being and that's why we have
partnered with calm the number one app
to help you reduce your anxiety and
stress and help you sleep better more
than 40 million people around the world
have downloaded it if you head over to
calm calm / Ben you get 25 percent off a
calm premium subscription which includes
guided meditations on issues like
anxiety stress and focus including a
brand new meditation each day there are
also sleep stories which are bedtime
stories for adults designed to help you
relax I mean they really are relaxing
heads the magical lavender fields of
southern France with Stephen Fry or
explore the moonlit jungles of Africa
with Leona Lewis they even have soothing
music and more you will be out like a
light so will your kids by the way it's
great for kids right now Ben Shapiro
listeners can get 25% off a comb premium
subscription at calm calm / Ben that CA
LM calm / Ben get unlimited access to
all of calms content today at calm calm
/ Benton get calm stop stressing calm
calm
/ Ben okay well the big breaking news
this morning that has up ends at our
entire show schedule is that Julian
Assange has now been arrested and this
of course is a very big deal because
Julian Assange was hiding out in the
equatorial embassy for seven years for
seven years and finally he was pulled
out of the embassy his Equatorial his
immunity was was removed from him and
they dragged him out of the Ecuadorian
Embassy in London now the reality is
that he had been a tool of the Russians
for a very long time according to the
best intelligence sources according to
the UK Daily Mail Julian Assange is
facing up to 12 months in a British
prison after he was found guilty of
skipping bail to avoid being extradited
to Sweden in 2012 to face allegations of
rape and sexual assault he finally
appeared in court today after he was
sensationally expelled from the
Ecuadorian Embassy in London where he
has been claiming political refuge for
the past seven years he is not a victim
in any way
I was legitimately under indictment and
then he skipped bail and now he's been
arrested he's no more a victim than
Roman Polanski would be a victim if he
were arrested for having skipped skipped
out on bail a judge described julian
assange defense as laughable and his
behavior is that of a narcissist who
cannot get beyond his own selfish
interests as the court heard he tried to
fight off arresting officers that didn't
go great for him Ecuador's decision to
revoke his political asylum this morning
so a diplomatic following of dominoes
with British police then dragging him
away in handcuffs to face charges
related to the bail conditions he defied
in 2012 in a sensational turn of events
he was then also charged by the United
States government with conspiring with
American whistleblower Chelsea Manning
would have been bradley manning at the
time to break a password to a classified
government computer in 2010 so they are
charging Assange in the united states
not for the publication of material
which could theoretically be a First
Amendment issue but instead they are
charging him for the violation of
hacking statutes he hasn't violated the
Espionage Act according to the DOJ his
violated hacking statutes according to
documents unsealed today the charge
relates to Assange his role in one of
the largest compromises of classified
information in US history he faces a
maximum jail term of five years he also
faces a court hearing on May 2nd
relating to his possible extradition to
the United States to contest the
computer hacking charges the court heard
today how Assange resisted arrest and
tried to barge past officers in an
attempt to return to his private room
within the embassy when they introduced
themselves about 10:00 a.m. telling them
this is unlawful Ecuadorian President
Lenin Moreno dramatically withdrew
Assange as Asylum status this morning
blaming his discourteous and aggressive
behavior in continuing to work with
WikiLeaks while housed at the Embassy
that's amazing how everybody's position
on WikiLeaks absolutely reversed over
the past six years seven years nine
years originally it was the right
looking at WikiLeaks as an evil Russian
front organization dedicated to spilling
American military secrets and putting
American lives in danger that assessment
I think was correct and then after
WikiLeaks started dumping out DNC
material started dumping out John
Podesta email then you heard people on
the right some people we won't name
names suggesting that WikiLeaks was
suddenly good and WikiLeaks was suddenly
somebody people who were worth listening
to they had valuable information
to provide well a couple things can be
true once one some of the information
that you provide in documents is
probably valuable information to you can
also be a tool of the Russians and one
of the world's worst humans and that
apparently is Julian Assange the arrest
came 24 hours after WikiLeaks accused
Ecuador of an extensive spying operation
adding that it assumed Intel had been
handed over to the administration of
Donald Trump's or Ecuador a sound Basic
Allah bit the hand that fed him and
Ecuador was like well guess what you
have diplomatic immunity because you're
in our embassy well here's what we can
do I think has removed his diplomatic
immunity president Moreno accused
Assange of violating the terms of his
Asylum by interfering in internal
affairs of other states as well as
blocking security security cameras and
mistreating guards the actual indictment
that came down from the DOJ alleges that
in March of 2010 Assange engaged in a
conspiracy with Chelsea Manning a former
intelligence analyst in the u.s. army to
assist Manning in cracking a password
stored on US Department of Defense
computers connected to the secret
Internet Protocol network a US
government network used for classified
documents and communications apparently
Manning who had access to the computers
in connection with her duties as an
intelligence analyst Manning was a man
at the time they should really say his
duties as an intelligence analyst since
we are speaking historically and if we
were speaking biologically is still a
man and because Manning was using the
computers to download classified records
to transmit to WikiLeaks cracking the
password would have allowed Manning to
log onto the computers under a username
that did not belong to her says the DOJ
such a deceptive measure would have made
it more difficult for investigators to
determine the source of the illegal
disclosures that is not a journalistic
tactic that is a hacking tactic a
journalistic tactic if somebody comes
with you comes to you with material and
then you print it a hacking tactic if
somebody says if you help me hack the US
Department of Defense then you can have
the resulting material that's a crime
during the conspiracy Manning and
Assange engaged in real-time discussions
regarding Manning's transmission of
classified records to Assange the
discussions also reflect Assange
activity reflect Assange actively
encouraging Manning to provide more
information during an exchange Manning
told Assange that quote after this
upload that's all I really have left to
which Assange replied curious eyes that
never run dry in my experience Assange
is now being charged with conspiracy to
commit computer intrusion he's presumed
innocent
lesson until proven guilty beyond a
reasonable doubt says the DOJ if
convicted he faces a max of five years
in prison now this comes shortly after
Chelsea Manning was arrested after
refusing to testify in a WikiLeaks case
just last month according to Business
Insider Manning was arrested in this had
been March 9th after she were after she
refuted li refused to testify in front
of a virginia grand jury about her
interactions with WikiLeaks and its
founder Julian Assange I found you in
contempt
judge cloud M Hilton told Manning at a
public ruling he said Manning will be
jailed either until you purge herself or
in or the end of the life of the grand
jury Manning said in a statement that
she'd been summoned to appear before a
secret grand jury on Wednesday in
response to each question she said she
answered object to that question and
refused to answer on the grounds that it
is violation of my first fourth and
sixth amendment and other statutory
rights well that is not a reason to not
testify in front of a grand jury
you have to plead the fifth but Chelsea
Manning has already been released from
prison after themed found guilty on
charges like these so there was no issue
of being prosecuted there was double
jeopardy forbids that so this was just
Chelsea Manning refusing to testify all
of the substantive questions pertaining
to my disclosures of information to the
public in 2010 answers I provided an
extensive testimony during my
court-martial in 2013 her statement
continued in January WikiLeaks said
federal prosecutors were working to get
witnesses to testify against Assange in
secret criminal proceedings being
conducted by the Trump administration
Manning told reporters I don't believe
in the grand jury process I don't
believe in the secrecy of this Manning
now believes in jail because that's
where Chelsea Manning currently is so
just as a reminder everybody has been
wrong about WikiLeaks at least once and
when I say everybody I don't mean
everybody some of us were saying that
WikiLeaks was a terrible organization
consistently for years but in the middle
of the 2016 election suddenly Julian
Assange began appearing on mainline
conservative television shows talking
about why it was important to release
all the Hillary Clinton documentation
suddenly Assange went from being a
figure of scorn and disgraced to being a
figure who ought to be loud 'add as a
figure of truth-telling
if your view of Julian Assange changed
because of the nature of the material
that he was revealing as opposed to the
methods used in gathering that material
or the lives put in danger because of
the release of that material then you
are a hack okay you are a hack if you
from Julian Assange is a villain to
Julian Assange is a hero and now back to
Julian Assange is a villain the whiplash
must be just incredible for you and if
you went from Julian Assange as a hero
to Julian Assange as villain that
whiplash must hurt pretty hard pretty
pretty well too because the fact is
we've known what we've needed to know
about Julian Assange on a root level
since 2011 commentary magazine had a
piece in at that time by Jonathan
Foreman talking about what exactly
Julian Assange had done and it's worth
reading as late as 2008 WikiLeaks was
insisting on its website that it was
completely neutral a conduit for
information and that would crowdsource
its analysis in the way that Wikipedia
the online encyclopedia written entirely
by unpaid volunteers allows public
contributions to its entry says
commentary there was little reason to
suspect that WikiLeaks had a special
animus against the United States in the
first three years of its existence
Wiki Wikipedia WikiLeaks received and
published hitherto secret documents
concerning a wide variety of entities
around the world these included a
confidential investigation by Kroll
Associates of official corruption in
Kenya UN documents concerning sexual
abuse by the organization's peacekeepers
in the Congo the tax returns of movie
star in tax refusenik Wesley Snipes and
private email stolen from Sarah Palin
and Holocaust and IR David Irving bigger
fish included the communications of a
Swiss bank allegedly engaged in money
laundering and secret materials from the
Church of Scientology during those three
years WikiLeaks also published a manual
of standard operating procedures of the
Gitmo detention facility that release
was intended to be embarrassing but it
had arguably been a benefit to the US
military because it showed that our
procedures were pretty good but that was
before collateral murder in 2010 the
focus of WikiLeaks turned directly and
exclusively to the US government and its
conduct since September 11th in the
summer it released the so called war
logs nearly half a million internal
Defense Department documents concerning
the wars in Iraq and Afghanistan that
was followed in November by the
publication of the State Department
cables indeed so focused was WikiLeaks
on these caches it became all but
impossible to access earlier postings on
other subjects or even submit new ones
this may well be because mega leaks as
Assange calls them naturally take
precedence over smaller ones on the
other hand it is possible that America
was dishonest target all along and that
his organization's earlier more
wide-ranging activities were designed to
build its credibility and create a false
impression of nutri
and objectivity before it went to war
with the United States government the
closer one examines astonishes various
pronouncements the more it looks like
someone who might engage into simulation
in order to mask a secret agenda the
circumstantial evidence for this
includes the disillusionment and
departure of key WikiLeaks team members
in September of 2010 so what exactly did
Assange do well he ignored the
Department of Defense's request the US
government's requested the State
Department's request for exact material
that could put Americans in direct path
of harm I'll give you some more
information about the entire Assange
debacle in just one second first let's
talk about something fun with twenty
three Emmys health and ancestry service
Kate you can explore 125 plus
personalized genetic reports that could
reveal the link between your DNA and
your health traits and more including
your chances of developing certain
diseases 23andme recently released their
newest health report on type-2 diabetes
which likely which tells you your
genetic likelihood for developing the
disease and gives you personalized
results and tools that could help with
prevention diabetes is a growing public
health challenge in the United States
obviously one in three adults in the
United States has pre diabetes but 90%
of people with pre-diabetes don't
actually know they have it
type 2 diabetes is influenced by
genetics it's not just lifestyle or
weight or sugar consumption or something
type 2 diabetes is a condition that
typically develops as we get older it's
caused by many factors including diet
lack of proper exercise weight gain our
genes 23andme z' type 2 diabetes report
offers insights into your genetic
likelihood for developing type 2
diabetes in empowers you with
personalized results and tools that
could help you prevent disease the
report was developed by 23andme
scientists using data and insights
gathered from more than 2.5 million
23andme customers who consented to
participate in our research
order your 23andme health and ancestry
service at 23andme comm slash Shapiro
that's the number two three and me.com
slash apparel again as 23andme comm
slash capiro it is useful in terms of
health also need all sorts of
information about your ancestry find out
if you're more Native American than
Elizabeth Warren apparently everyone on
earth except for me is again that is
23andme comm slash up hero 23andme comm
slash Shapiro go check them out right
now 23andme comm slash up hero alrighty
so a little more information on
WikiLeaks and Julian Assange
Sanj insisted on publishing the Afghan
war logs without redacting names and
other personal details to protect the
lives of those mentioned in them even
after five major human rights
organizations pled with him to do so in
a joint email his response to this was
to demand that the five organizations
assist in the tax of the tasks of
redaction he also said that WikiLeaks
would need 700,000 dollars to go through
remaining unpublished documents by that
point 77,000 out of 92 thousand
documents had already been released and
despite astonishes initial claims that
the names of Afghan informants had been
redacted newspapers like the New York
Times found that this was often not the
case when Amnesty International
suggested a conference call to discuss
collaboration Assange said I'm very busy
I have no time to deal with people who
prefer to do nothing but cover their
asses
Assange would not consider delaying
publication the same was true of the
subsequent much bigger release of iraq
war documents in the autumn it was that
decision that prompted a major internal
revolt at wikileaks according to reports
in Wired the organisation's German
spokesman Daniel domscheit-berg
confronted Assange about his autocratic
and secretive behavior and Assange
responded by accusing domscheit-berg of
leaking information within WikiLeaks to
a columnist for Newsweek convinced that
domscheit-berg was the source of the
leak to Newsweek Assange says quote I am
investigating a serious security breach
are you refusing to answer
domscheit-berg replied that everyone in
the organisation was concerned about the
news that Assange might be charged with
rape in Sweden he also pressed Assange
about the Iraq documents at one point
exclaiming you are not anyone's King or
God Assange then forced him to resign
effectively speaking all of this is a is
a disaster area and has been a disaster
area for the United States for a very
long time as this commentary magazine
article points out the idea that Assange
is engaged in a campaign against the
United States is supported by 2008 leak
that had little or no justification on
the grounds of transparency in the
interest of the public a classified 2004
report that included details of the
workings of the US Army's war lock
system for jamming the homemade bombs
called IEDs set off by cellphone a radio
transmitter the report concerned the
problematic way the jammers interfered
with regular military communications but
its publication ensured that anyone
anywhere in the world who wanted to
figure out how to defeat the Warlock now
had the means to do so
WikiLeaks defenders said there's no
reason not to publish but the State
Department
the Defense Department said why are you
publishing all of this stuff it's a
mistake and it's gonna put people in
danger his his fans have suggested that
Assange was in fact doing a world of
good by releasing all of this material
but asan in fact was doing a tremendous
damage to innocent people by releasing
all of these documents the via via I
mean it's it's he was allowing
persecution of people who are
coordinating with the United States
government to fight the Taliban in
Afghanistan that's some pretty bad stuff
that's some pretty bad stuff I mean even
the nation came out against him in 2016
talking about how he was undermining he
was undermining dissenters in foreign
countries it's pretty terrible it's
pretty terrible stuff Julian Assange and
WikiLeaks have have engaged in really
really bad activity so it is a good
thing for the world that Assange was
arrested today it's a good thing Boston
University there's a fellow named Paul
hare who teaches over at Boston
University
he's a britain's former ambassador to
Cuba he says when Edward Snowden thinks
you have a big mouth you may have a
problem
former NSA whistleblower Snowden has
criticized WikiLeaks for failing to
redact sensitive information even in the
hack DNC emails allowing credit card and
social security numbers of party donors
and guests to tumble into public view
and this has been going on for years so
all the people who are out there today
defending Julian Assange who acted as
essentially a front for the Russian
government again if you were wildly
inconsistent on this issue I think that
you have some looking in the mirror to
be done
oh yeah meanwhile major controversy has
broken out on the hill Attorney General
William Barr has gone on offense against
the so-called deep state he didn't use
that term but that is the term that is
being used in the press today he is
suggesting that there needs to be a full
investigation of the outset and conduct
of the Trump Russia collusion
investigation so he's testifying on the
hill yesterday and he asked some
questions he said he was asked first of
all whether he thought spying against
the Trump campaign had happened he said
yes I do think spying against the Trump
campaign happened this has been the the
quote that has driven a thousand thing
pieces right here I think spy
on a political campaign is a big deal
it's a big deal
I think it's important to look at that
and I'm not just I'm not talking about
the FBI necessarily but intelligence
agencies more broadly so you're not
you're not suggesting though that spine
occurred I guess you could I think there
was a spying did occur yes I think
spying did occur well obviously he is
correct about that spying in the generic
sense did occur I mean there was
surveillance against Carter page
including retroactive surveillance of
his emails presumably there is also
spying on George papadopolis via use of
human informants the question as Barr
makes clear is that these surveillance
could have been proper or could have
been improper and he doesn't know the
answer to that so here's Bauer
explaining what I mean is we need to
find out whether this was improper
surveillance or whether this was proper
surveillance I just want to make it
clear looking thinking back on all the
different colloquy here that I am NOT
saying that improper surveillance
occurred I'm saying that I am concerned
about it and looking into it that's all
okay so that of course is true but that
has driven people up a wall that is
driven people absolutely up a wall
despite the fact there's an ongoing
investigation into exactly these
questions already
as we mentioned yesterday on the radio
show Justice Department Inspector
General Michael Horowitz is already
investigating possible abuse of the
Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Act by
the Justice Department and the FBI
according to William Barr during a house
appropriation subcommittee hearing on
the Justice Department's budget proposal
by are explained that the office of the
Inspector General has a pending
investigation of the FISA process in the
Russia investigation he says that this
will be complete by May or June and you
can see the panic beginning to breakout
intimal Craddock circles own no is
Michael Horowitz the investig-- the the
Inspector General over at the DOJ the
guy who effectively found that Peter
struck and Lisa Paige and other members
of the intelligence community had
overstepped their mandate in the Hillary
investigation and botched the
investigation for political reasons and
also had exposed the intelligence
agencies to justified criticism over
their political bias is that guy now
going to turn his eyes to the conduct of
the Trump Russia investigation because
that could have some dire effects
particularly for some people who are
involved in that investigate
because it's not just a question of how
that investigation was begun maybe it
was begun under good auspices maybe
George papadopolis was suspicious and
thus they decided they needed to look
into him let's even assume that the FISA
warrants against Carter page was good
although that's a lot more doubtful
especially if the intelligence agencies
knew that the seal dossier which was
used as a strong basis for that FISA
warrant was a bunch of nonsense but
there's another side to that
investigation and that is all of the
leaks that were coming out of the Obama
administration about the progress of the
Trump Russia investigation some of those
leaks have been traced to people like
James clapper clapper of course the
former head of Obama's CIA all of this
has also been traced back to a lot of
the bias that was present at the top
levels of the Intelligence Committee
people like John Brennan over at the CIA
know under John Brennan seems to be
running scared he was on MSNBC last
night he says well Barr you know he just
sounded like a personal lawyer for Trump
unfortunately I think over the past
several weeks I've been very
disappointed in attorney general bar I
had higher expectations for him he
shaped the narrative after the mole
report he in fact then also had this
testimony today that I think was very
carefully nuanced as a way to try to
support the Donald Trump's positions so
he acted more like that a personal
lawyer for Donald Trump today rather
than the attorney general okay he can
say that and it's and he can believe
that and you can hear the media
repeating this there is something deeply
ironic about a media that was firmly
convinced that Robert Muller was going
to find president Trump guilty of
collusion a media that was that was
hanging on every word from the Intel
community and from the DOJ and the
Muller investigation and the FBI when it
came to the collusion report and
suddenly they are really uncurious about
exactly who started this investigation
how it got started the conduct of the
investigation suddenly all that stuff is
deeply boring to them I wonder why I
wonder why could it have something to do
with the political agenda involved we'll
get to that in just one second first can
you believe it's already April time has
a habit of getting away but if you've
got a mortgage or kids anybody depending
on your income you're gonna have to
spend some of that precious time getting
life insurance if you need life
insurance but you don't want to spend a
lot of time comparing it you should get
policy genius a try policy genius is the
easy way to buy life insurance online in
just two minutes you can
comparequotes from the top insurers and
find your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork in red tape no Commission's no
hidden fees just more time saved for you
and policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they also make it easy to
find the right home insurance auto
insurance disability insurance they are
one-stop-shop for financial protection
so if you need life insurance but you're
short on time head on over to policy
genius calm and comparequotes policy
genius is easy it saves you money not to
belabor the point but it's fast policy
genius spend less time comparing life
insurance more time and doing literally
anything else be an adult
go get your life insurance make sure
your family is taken care of it's not
gonna take you very long because you're
using policy genius which means that you
can do it quickly
you can get the best price on this stuff
that's not just life insurance it's
other forms of insurance to be
responsible go check it out policy
genius.com
policy genius.com all right so as I say
the media wildly uncurious about the
allegations by William bar that spying
that may have been a prop improper may
have occurred during the 2016 election
cycle and beyond against Team Trump the
media are united in their disdain for
such statements whereas they were
perfectly happy to take all of the
advice they could from politically
motivated actors like James Comey
and John Brennan and James clapper and
all these people who suggested they had
inside information and knowledge that
collusion occurred they're perfectly
happy to push that propaganda out there
day after day and it didn't turn out to
be true and now they don't even want to
ask the simple question they can't even
handle 24 hours of being asked questions
about how exactly the FISA warrants
against Carter Paige went down or
whether Lisa Paige and Peter struck were
instrumental in driving the Trump Russia
collusion investigation for political
reasons or whether the leaks that were
coming from that investigation were in
fact criminal in any way they're so
uncurious here's Chuck Todd being deeply
uncurious it doesn't matter what the
truth is does it I mean I hate to say
this now but that's the whole point it
feels like we that basically the
Attorney General gas-lit the country so
he's amazing how he's happy to say this
attorney at general gas let the country
but Loretta Lynch man you know that lady
was just she was wonderful Eric Holder
who called himself a wingman for
President Obama and was held in contempt
by
that guy was great but William bar he's
gaslighting in the country when he says
these people were spied on
they were spied on there's no question
whether they were spied on they were the
question is whether that spine was
legitimate and that's what he is saying
he is going to get to the bottom of
Andrew McCarthy has a piece over at
foxnews.com
today talking about this he says in his
testimony on Wednesday before a Senate
Appropriations Committee subcommittee
Attorney General William Barr made
statements that were so clearly correct
they should be no more controversial
than asserting that the sky is blue the
fact that they are causing consternation
is what should alarm people Bart told
senators I think spying did occur the
question bar elaborated is whether it
was adequately predicated because spying
on a political campaign is a big deal we
should long ago have known what the
rationale was you know as surely as
you're reading this that if an incumbent
Republican administration had greenlit a
DOJ and FBI investigation of the
Democratic Party's presidential campaign
we would already be fully informed about
what triggered the investigation
Democrats would have been unified in
demanding it the media would have echoed
those demands in an endless loop and if
there'd been an abuse of power all the
pertinent heads would by now have rolled
instead we're dealing with the Obama
administration directing an
investigation of the campaign of Donald
Trump candidate Trump was regarded by
many in the media and political
establishment as the most unfit
presidential candidate ever a man who
would certainly have been predisposed to
engage in a corrupt plot with Russia to
manipulate the electorate for more than
two years that has been the dominant
narrative says Andrew McCarthy as a
result many in the media Democrats even
many Republicans have ignored claims of
political spying even as the evidence
that it took place mounted indeed
mounted to the point that whether spying
occurred is no longer contestable the
narrative has now shifted to the claim
that the target of the spine was not
Trump himself but rather a few bad
apples working in his campaign
so here is what McCarthy says he says
there's a presumption in this country
against the exploitation of law
enforcement and intelligence authorities
for political purposes and in particular
against political spying but a
presumption is not an unbreakable rule
if there are real evidence that the
opposition party's presidential nominee
was conspiring with a foreign power to
commit crimes especially espionage to
influence the campaign the incumbent
administration would have an obligation
to investigate and to take appropriate
action what is appropriate is dictated
by the circumstances this is a much
misunderstood principle the fact that
the opening of an investigation may be
justifiable does not by itself justify
all investing
tactics that might be used and this is
correct it's quite possible that this as
I've said many times that this
investigation was initiated under solid
auspices and then it moved beyond its
boundaries because there are politically
motivated actors in positions of high
authority that's been my going theory
here because there's a norm against
political spying opening an
investigation of the opposition
political party is not like opening an
investigation of a Mafia family or a
suspected drug conspiracy says McCarthy
an investigation of a political campaign
should not be open unless there is
significant evidence of wrongdoing using
informants to spy on a campaign or its
operatives is extremely intrusive and
has a high potential for abuse it should
not be done based on a few disturbing
connections between campaign surrogates
and foreign powers moreover if spying is
to be conducted under the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act FISA must
be followed to conduct FISA surveillance
of an American citizen suspected of
being an agent of a foreign power there
must be probable cause that the American
citizen is knowingly not unwittingly
engaged in clandestine activities on
behalf of the foreign power so he
continues along these lines and and this
is this is correct I mean he's making
the case that the Attorney General is
right to press for these answers and
that he has not said anything wrong but
the media and the Democrats are going
crazy over this how dare William Barr
suggest that maybe something was wrong
in this investigation or that anything
went wrong even though we already know
something went wrong okay we actually
already know that something happened
here the prioritization of the Trump
Russia collusion investigation over the
Hillary Clinton investigation was
already found by Michael Horowitz his IG
report from the DOJ Michael Horowitz his
report found that Peter struck and Lisa
Paige decided to prioritize they decided
to push forward the Trump Russia
investigation at the expense of the
Hillary investigation it ended up
hurting Hillary because the information
that was on Anthony Weiner server they
knew about that a month before they
announced it but they put it on the back
burner because they didn't think it was
important or as they thought the Trump
Russia stuff was deeply important
nonetheless the the Democrats are trying
to draw a narrative that bar is a
political actor and that because Barr is
a political actor he's going to shield
Trump from problems and the evidence
that that he is actually covering for
Trump is the fact that he's even
bringing up the possibility of
corruption from high officials inside
the
halogens community here's Nancy Pelosi
doing this routine the chief law
enforcement officer of our country is
going off the rails yesterday and today
he is the Attorney General of the United
States of America not the Attorney
General of Donald Trump
okay well that that's hilarious because
I don't remember her saying the same
thing about any of Barack Obama's
attorney generals including Eric Holder
who was held in contempt by Congress
it's pretty incredible okay in just a
second I'm gonna get to controversy
breaking out over Ilhan Omar because
there is a lot going on there but first
you're gonna have to go and subscribe at
daily wire.com go to daily wire.com
right now subscribe for $9.99 a month
when you do you get the rest of this
show live you get the rest of andrew
kleavon's show live you get Michael
Moses show live you get Matt Walsh's
show live all sorts of goodies plus two
additional hours every single day two
additional hours of me every single
afternoon I mean we are slaving away for
you folks we are working our fingers to
the bone we are really really working
hard to bring you the best in content
but you can only get that really I made
on a full daily basis and the archives
and everything else when you subscribe
for $9.99 a month or $99 a year which
also brings you this the greatest in all
beverage vessels cast your eyes upon it
it is indeed magnificent feel the the
energy that surges therefrom all you
have to do is spend 99 bucks and get
that annual subscription you will really
enjoy it also you get the Sunday special
early we have a great Sunday special
coming up this Sunday this one features
Lauren Chen also known formerly as
roaming millennial and it was great
conversation about what's up with the
Millennials and why are they crazy
here's what some of that sounded like
Millennials are in favor of socialism or
at least they have a very positive view
of socialism Millennials don't know who
people like Pol Pot or Stalin or Mao are
which is kind of to me what being a
millennial is all about like all of the
enthusiasm with none of the knowledge
[Music]
so you can check that out go over to
daily wired icon becoming subscriber
also when you subscribe over at daily
wired comm you get extra questions
behind the pay what all sorts of goodies
and if you subscribe at YouTube or
iTunes then you can get a lot of our
free stuff you get everything that is
free leave us a review we always
appreciate it we're the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
you
so some big controversy breaking out now
over Ilhan Omar who continues to just be
a nightmare for Democrats she's a
nightmare for Democrats because she says
terrible things on a fairly regular
basis well one of the terrible things
that she has said in the last few weeks
she spoke at a an event for the council
on american-islamic relations now it is
important to note that the Council on
american-islamic relations is not in
fact a moderate or reformed Muslim group
the Council on american-islamic
relations was named as a co-conspirators
an unindicted co-conspirator in the Holy
Land Foundation trial the Holy Land
Foundation was a front group for raising
money for Hamas care was founded in 1994
it was not founded after 9/11 it was
founded specifically to beat back
supposedly all of the Islamophobia that
was so prevalent in the United States
while Ilhan Omar in the midst it's a
deeply empty anti-israel group obviously
they have many anti-semitic connections
they have connections to terror groups
at least in terms of the personnel who
have shuttled between various groups in
any case
Ilhan Omar spoke at an event for care
just a few weeks back and when she spoke
at this event she was in the middle of
allegations of anti-semitism because she
has repeatedly said brutally
anti-semitic things well in the middle
of her speech she was talking about how
it was that all Muslims in the United
States had been blamed for the actions
of a few Muslims on 9/11 but the way she
spoke about it raised some hackles and
for pretty good reason because they
recognized that some people did
something and that all of us were
starting to lose access to our civil
liberties okay some people did something
some people did something so that
description has raised some hackles
because 9/11 wasn't some people did
something 9/11 was a vicious terrorist
attack the worst terrorist attack in the
history of the United States by a huge
margin it was the worst it was the worst
attack on the United States since Pearl
Harbor and it wasn't just some people
did something now her defenders are
saying well what she's trying to do
there she's trying to contrast some
people did something that all of us were
blamed except that what she said there
was that some people did it wasn't
a Terran horrible terrorist attack
occurred on American soil and then they
blamed us it was some people did
something is this dismissive language
with regard to terrorism and
unfortunately that fits in with her
record with regard to how she has
treated terrorism in the past
representative Ilhan Omar I mean she
recommended lightness in sentencing for
Isis recruits from Minnesota back in
2016 now Omar has been suggesting over
and over and over again that anyone who
rips around this stuff in his is an
islamaphobe but this has nothing to do
in my view with mainstream Islam or
Islam ten erally this has to do with her
being a bad person who spends an awful
lot of time defending terrorists on the
grounds that their ideology may not be
wrong it's just their action that is
wrong here is the here's where I get
that so she wrote this letter back in
2016 to a judge on the basis of a his
sentencing that was taking place of nine
defendants who had been convicted of
trying to join Isis and here is what she
wrote to this judge in November of 2016
she was already a state representative
in Minnesota quote as you undoubtedly
deliberate with great caution the
sentencing of nine recently convicted
Somali American men I bring to your
attention the ramifications of
sentencing young men who made a
consequential mistake two decades in
federal prison so is a consequential
mistake to join Isis weird mistake weird
I mean this isn't somebody getting
caught up in a drug bust you were trying
to join Isis she says Society will have
no expectations of the then to be 50 or
60 year-olds released prisoners if they
serve a couple of decades in prison it
will view them with distrust and
revulsion such punitive measures not
only lack efficacy they inevitably
create an environment in which extremism
it can flourish aligning with the
presupposition of terrorist recruitment
Americans do not accept you and continue
to trivialize your value instead of
being a nobody be a martyr in other
words if we punish terrorists then
terrorists are going to crop up because
they will rightfully be be feeling that
America has marginalized them and she
makes this absolutely clear in the rest
of the letter she says the best
deterrent of fanaticism is a system of
compassion we must alter our attitude
approach if we truly want to effect
change we should refocus our efforts on
inclusion and rehabilitation here is the
key sentence a long term prison sentence
for one who chose violence to combat
direct marginalization is a statement
that our justice system misunderstands
the guilty so in other words the big
problem for terrorists is that they
choose violence but really their victims
really they're victims of direct
marginalization in the United States and
so they really shouldn't go to prison I
mean they made a bad choice about the
whole violence and joining Isis thing
but as far as their general perspective
as bap being marginalized not only are
they right they're even more right if
you sentenced them to prison so there's
a catch-22 if somebody tries to join
Isis that's because they were
marginalized but if you arrest them and
pretend them to prison you're
marginalizing them which makes them want
to join Isis the desire to commit
violence is not inherent to people says
Ilhan Omar back in this 2016 letter it
is the consequences of systematic
alienation people see violent solutions
where the process established for
enacting guilt is inaccessible to them
so in other words people are
marginalized people are cast out and
then they want to kill Americans
fueled by disaffection turn to malice if
the guilty were willing to kill and be
killed fighting perceived injustice
imagine the consequence of them here and
I believe you can be rehabilitated I
want you to become part of my community
and together we will thrive so release
these people from prison so that you are
treating them with kindness and then
they will all be better off now this is
why I say this has nothing to do with
ohon omar and islam per se this has much
more to do with ohon omar being a
radical leftist because barack obama
says very much the same thing in the
introduction to Dreams from My Father in
dreams for my father I pointed this out
when when the book came out in rooms
from my phone when you ran for president
in rooms from her father Barack Obama
says that he has seen that aspera on the
faces of people ranging from the south
side of Chicago to people in in Jakarta
Indonesia and it comes from the same
source namely marginalization if we stop
marginalizing people they'll stop being
terrorists that's a perverse view of
what drives terrorism ideology drives
terrorism there are a lot of
dispossessed people in the United States
they're not going and trying to join
Isis and there are a lot of people who
are just possessed in the United States
they're not going and joining white
supremacist groups the notion that
marginalization is an excuse or justify
ocation for joining a terrorist group is
pretty perverse and the way that she
brushes off somebody trying to join Isis
should tell you something about her
generalized attitude toward terrorism I
still would love to hear her condemn
Kumasi she ever done that has she ever
actually condemned Hamas I don't know
I'll have to check that out I suspect
that neither she nor Rasheeda Talib
would be completely comfortable with
doing so at least not without starting
to bash Israel as the great oppressive
force in the Middle East and as I
mentioned terror has been she was saying
all this in front of care which has been
a serious problem for a very very long
time and care has actively defended Sami
al-arian who is a Palestinian Islamic
Jihad financier care was endorsed by the
American Muslim task force for civil
rights and election for a worldwide
rolling fast in support of Sami al-arian
who was a terrorist care advised the
family of the suspected terrorist after
the deadly 2015 San Bernardino terrorist
attack and held a press conference
featuring the families of the killers
and then offered legal assistance to the
family they they're their national board
president in 2008 a guy named parvat
Achmed described terror organizations
like Hamas and Hezbollah as part of the
political processes in their societies
just like the Irish Republican Army was
part of the political process in their
society obviously cares the anti-israel
agenda dates back to its founding by
leaders of the Islamic Association for
Palestine a Hamas affiliated
anti-semitic propaganda organization
that last quote is from the
anti-defamation league the care founder
knew Hillel watt it said in 1994 he was
in support of Hamas so she was saying
all of this in front of a group that has
a long-standing ease of treatment with
regard to terrorism asking questions
about whether she is also soft on
terrorism as she sits on the Foreign
Affairs Committee is not as llama phobic
that is rational that is something that
we should be doing and meanwhile the
Democratic presidential race continues
to heat up with Bernie Sanders
introducing Medicare for all his
Medicare for all bill is the most
extreme version of the Medicare for all
bill that would eliminate private
insurance and he announced his Medicare
for all bill by basically suggesting
that insurance companies would be
relegated to doing nose jobs that
would be their new job they would be
relegated to doing elective surgeries
and instead the government would take
care of you in every aspect health care
is a human right not a privilege
together we are going to end the
international embarrassment of the
United States of America our great
country being the only major nation on
earth not to guarantee health care to
all as a right that is going to end all
that is going and he's trying to force
the other Democrats into either
embracing his most extreme position or
into running away from it Cory Booker
hilariously has signed on to Bernie
Sanders Medicare for all and then openly
admitted that the thing is going nowhere
he is openly he says nah you know I
don't think going anywhere but I don't
want to be outflanked by Bernie so I'm
just gonna gonna jump on this bandwagon
Bernie Sanders still the ideological
thought leader of the Democratic Party
very odd that so many of the Democrats
are interested in moving into his Lane
as opposed to moving into Biden's Lane
the only Democrat who's even attempted
to move into Joe Biden's Lane thus far
was Peabody judge and he's outperforming
in the polls specifically because of it
so Democrats keep following Bernie like
lemmings across that over that cliff
when the truth is that Biden is sort of
standing over on the side waving at
everybody and taking 40% of the vote
it's pretty impressive other Democratic
candidates are jumping in as well or
thinking about it and they're doing so
in very odd ways Eric's wha-whoa is a
Democratic Congress person from
California and he has announced his
campaign in the weirdest possible way so
first he went on Stephen Colbert and
announced his campaign this is the
Congress person who suggested that gun
ownership in the United States could not
help defend against government
encroachment because the government
would just nuke you well yesterday he
decide to get even weirder he tweeted
this out quote I am running for
president of the United States of
America I see you I hear you I'm for you
I am you wow that's creepy that's very
weird I'm I'm not sure what he's going
for with the IMU and that actually the
execrable Michael Knowles had a pretty
solid take on this maybe the
his plan for becoming president because
the arocs wha-whoa is all of us then
he's also Donald Trump and Joe Biden so
if they win then he wins I guess but I
am you it's about the dad that's about
the creepiest slogan I've ever heard I
am me what is this faceoff with Nicolas
Cage he's sneering into the camera I am
you know as man I gotta say this is a
weird crew I mean the Democrats are a
very very strange crew they should all I
think create slogans that are based on
this simple premise this sort of is so
Eric's walls slogan could be IMU and
then Kirsten Gillibrand could be I am
who and then you could have and then you
could have Joe Biden slogan I'm behind
you and maybe maybe cory booker slogan
could be I am Spartacus I feel like that
would probably be good that wasn't
actually the weirdest presidential move
of the day believe it or not Terry
McAuliffe the former governor of
Virginia and Clinton ista he put out a
tweet that makes no sense at all it is a
picture of I have been informed a crab
sitting atop the head of an alligator
and the crab is labeled Terry McAuliffe
and the alligator is labeled Donald
Trump and I guess this is supposed to be
an anti-trump meme but I'm getting from
it is that Terry McAuliffe is going to
team up with Donald Trump to create the
most amazing biological transformer ever
the crab Gator Alexandra Petri over at
the Washington Post no right winger
tweeted out tweeted out Donald Trump
wears me as a hat is a bold
it's a bold campaign slogan but I guess
you can go there so that's that's
exciting stuff the Democrats I just got
to say I think that their their shocking
lack of ability to capitalize on a rich
political situation for them is pretty
astounding it's pretty saying the good
news for them is they all know that the
media's gonna defend them no matter what
I mean it can be as bad at this as
possible and the media I mean Eric's
wawel appeared on Stephen Colbert who by
the way is awful quick note on Stephen
Colbert he spent last night trying to
rehabilitate Ilhan Omar for
anti-semitism I don't remember him
trying to do this with Steve King on
white nationalism or for that matter
Donald Trump on the Mexican
but here he was trying to rehabilitate
an open anti-semite I'm glad that our
late night television hosts have their
priorities in order
you were criticized for saying some
things that some people on the right
specifically but also some Democrats saw
as being possibly anti-semitic you got
some support from some people think
Glenn Greenwald might have tweeted in
support to you and you tweeted back to
him that the attacks on you were all
about the Benjamins meaning a pack and a
lobbyist for the State of Israel by
saying that you were accused of
anti-semitism again what does it you
then apologized at the insistence of
Nancy Pelosi so it's not just
Republicans who had problems with what
you had said or done it was also some
Democrats what was that process like
what was that like to be a cudgel like
that being used as a political cudgel I
got when you began your service oh my
god what was it like being used as a
political console you just told a story
about an anti-semite who kept doubling
down on anti-semitism and your question
is what was it like being used as a
cudgel like that how about why did you
say these anti-semitic things lady how
about you said a bunch of anti-semitic
stuff that's bad how about why did you
say some people did something about 9/11
there seemed like some serious questions
to be asked here between Newsweek
magazine putting out a cover suggesting
that she was changing the conversation
about israel and stephen colbert asking
her how rough it was to be an
anti-semite my goodness the media doing
yeoman's work these days okay time for
some things I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like today
you know every so often you got to take
a break from the from the cares of the
day and read some sports I am big on
sports books one of the best sports
authors out there is Jeff Perlman had a
book that came out a few years ago about
the Showtime Lakers and I'm a Celtics
fan and this book is just great
it is it is an inside look at magic and
Kareem and Pat Riley so if you're a
Lakers fan I'm from LA is the only
Lakers thing I will ever recommend check
out Showtime book by Jeff Perlman who
really is a terrific author you can go
get that right now other things that I
like so breaking news Michael avenatti
is indicted on 36 criminal counts by a
federal grand jury in Los Angeles the
indictment is not just about the
attempted extortion of Nike it is also
about him apparently being the worst
person in the world the only times
reported
today that the indictment accused
avenatti of hiding a four million dollar
legal settlement in favor of a mentally
ill paraplegic client four years hero of
the resistance also of hiding a 2.75
million dollar settlement for another
client avenatti allegedly used the money
to help pay for the purchase of a
private jet the guy's a sociopath most
of the money for the paraplegic client
according to the indictment quoted by
The Times was funneled to a company that
managed a vanadis racecar team and to
his Coffee Company global baristas which
operated the Tully's chain in all the
newspaper reported five clients were
allegedly ripped off by avenatti for
millions of dollars who also is accused
of using shell companies and bank
accounts to hide the purported theft Wow
guys his delight he was nearly president
in that fun things were going great guys
hey other things that I like you know
we're no more things that I like it's
time for some things that I hate okay so
things that I hate today so Neil
deGrasse Tyson is in irritating human he
is tendentious and he is sneering and he
is annoying and he makes everything
worse the OL deGrasse Tyson spends a lot
of his time basically pretending to be
the voice I mean this is a guy who
seriously proposed that there be a
country called ration alia where we just
use reason to govern ourselves and it
never occurred to him that maybe people
arrive at different conclusions by using
reason depending on their premises he's
that type of person who knows all the
things all the things so yesterday he
tweeted out a bit regarding the first
ever image of a supermassive black hole
he tweeted out scientists we've produced
the first ever image of a supermassive
black hole 55 million light years away
response ooh
scientists we've concluded that humans
are catastrophic Lee warming earth
response that conflicts with what I want
to be true so it must be false okay a
couple of notes on this one different
types of scientists theoretical physics
not quite the same thing as climatology
which has a lot of intervening factors
there's broad disagreement among
scientists about just how much global
warming is being caused by human
activity and how sensitive the climate
is to human activity third one of the
reasons that we are amazed by the
actual production of the image of the
black hole is one because the capacity
of science to do that is pretty
incredible and two because it actually
fulfilled the prediction one of the
problems a lot of critics of a global
warming literature have is that the
computer modeling on global warming has
not in fact produced the picture of the
black hole if we're using the analogy it
has produced models that have been well
off
for example John Kerry in 2009 parroting
the consensus view talked about how the
Arctic would be ice-free within five
years is the Arctic ice free today it is
not you have sea ice which is melting at
a rate that the Arctic Ocean
now increasingly is exposed in five
years scientists predict we will have
the first ice-free Arctic summer that
exposes more ocean to sunlight ocean is
dark it consumes more of the heat from
the sunlight which then accelerates the
rate of of the of the melting and
warming rather than the ice sheet and
the snow that used to reflect it back up
into the atmosphere there is truth to
the fact that the Arctic the Arctic ice
is in fact melting that's true but it
was not gone by 2014 they keep pushing
the estimates out so that's not to say
that global warming data is all false or
that global warming isn't taking place
or the global warming isn't human-caused
it is to say there's a lot more
uncertainty about how much of that is
preventable what has to be done how much
of it is happening there's a there's
pretty broad there's a pretty broad
range we read the IPCC report they have
three separate estimates as to the the
change in climate that's going to happen
over the next century they have an
extreme estimate and they have a
moderate estimate and they have a mild
estimate okay when we don't know what's
going to show up yet and we have two
predicates based on that so that stuff
is pretty obnoxious okay other things
that I hate today
so Chrissy Teigen was at some sort of
conference and she was asked about what
women should say more what is the phrase
that women should say more and here was
her comeback if there was one word you
would help particularly women use more
frequently well put that one word be
[Laughter]
okay so here's the deal that isn't
phrase that pretty much everybody should
use less frequently they should use it
less frequently how about thank you how
about that's a phrase people should use
more Chrissy Teigen has a pretty awesome
life she's pretty great life now there
are times when women should say that to
two men when they are sexually harassed
or abused when men do bad things to them
when people generally do bad things to
you then telling them to f off is a
time-honored tradition but the notion
that women are so victimized that what
they need to be saying more often is f
you as opposed to thank you is absurd
men the same thing we should all be
saying thank you to each other look at
the world we live in look at the ease of
life Chrissy Teigen flies around a
private jet with John Legend protected
by security living high on the hog and
she's asked what is something women
should say more and the answer isn't
thank you it's fu there's a tremendous
attitude of ingratitude that has spammed
the nation and it's reflecting itself in
both policy and politics we despise each
other because we can't say thank you to
each other we despise our politics
because we think that politics is
supposed to take care of all of our
problems and we despise our own
civilization because we failed to say
thank you to the people who came before
us and built that civilization I really
think that that that Maya that one small
statement is a real indicator of the of
why Western civilization is crumbling at
the root in gratitude in gratitude
pretty insane stuff okay so we'll be
back here a little bit later today with
two additional hours go check that out
right now if you've not picked up a copy
of my book the right side of history you
certainly should it was number four on
the New York Times bestseller list again
this week that's its third week third
week on the New York Times bestseller
list we've sold hundreds of thousands of
copies please keep going out there
buying for your friends I think it's an
important book it speaks about some of
the themes that we talked about on the
show every day go check that out we'll
see you here later today for two
additional hours if you subscribe if not
we'll see you here tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam SIA
Vettes audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant NIC Sheehan the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey guys
over on the Matt Walsh show today Pope
Benedict has emerged from seclusion to
discuss the sex abuse crisis and he has
some insights that are true but also
pretty startling and we'll talk about
that also according to a recent report
Google has a running blacklist and
you'll never guess who's on it
we'll discuss also we'll talk about
black holes and The Lion King and
biblical end times prophecies there's a
lot to cover on the show today so come
over and check it out